oui grèce s'est réveillé ce matin avec
cette nouvelle l'interpellation et la
garde à vue de johnathan d'annales pour
beaucoup d'habitants que nous avons
rencontré ce matin ici dans la ville à
gré avec philippe herbet beaucoup nous
reparler des obsèques où ils ont pu voir
le mari d'alexia daval et pleurer donc
beaucoup ne comprennent pas mais
certains préfèrent rester prudents et
attendre les suites de l'enquêté les
suites de cette garde à vue je vous
propose d'écouter les habitants que nous
avons rencontré connais juste les
parents de la jeune femme c'est tout
l'enquète va se poursuivre voilà on
attend tous les résultats
moi je n'en pense rien tant que je ne
sais pas tant que pour que leur n'a rien
dit moi ça ne perde pas ses yeux sur
tout ce que les gens disent les gens ils
racontent plein de choses et normalement
ça c'est non je peux d'accord